[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sont plus tarder voici le
sommaire exportations filiales à
l'international présence au salon
mondial de l'innovation technologique à
las vegas focus dans ce numéro sur ces
entreprises saint-quentinoise qui se
développe dans le monde entier
lander ayadi fondateur de la start up in
intel numérique sera également en
plateau
vous faites peut-être partie des 14
millions de français utilisent et
linkedin
au début du mois une déclinaison locale
de ce réseau professionnel a vu le jour
à versailles
nous verrons en quoi il consiste enfin
campagne de financement participatif
pour la start-up versaillaise vite vu
bien vu ou encore carte interactive des
espaces de coworking dans notre région
nous ferons un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité économique dans notre
département
mais avant de développer tous et ils y
trouveront ce magazine avec un chiffre
de 130 4 c'est le nombre d'entreprises
internationales présentes sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
cela représente un peu plus de 13 mille
quatre cents emplois
parmi les secteurs l'automobile le
commerce ou encore la santé
à saint quentin en yvelines qui
accueille des entreprises à capitaux
étrangers sur son territoire mais qui
est également bien présente à
l'international
nous en parlerons bien sûr en détail
dans quelques minutes
c'est un réseau social professionnel qui
met en avant les parcours et compétences
de chacun il s'agit du réseau linkedin
vous possédez peut-être un compte ou
bien connaissez quelqu'un qui en
possèdent un au début du mois une
déclinaison locale de ce réseau a été
lancée à versailles et à cette occasion
à grégory canale étaient sur place
discutez réseauter et échanger des
cartes de visite dans une ambiance
décontractée
c'est l'esprit des linkedin locale un
concept né dans les pays anglophones
pour faciliter les rencontres et
développer les opportunités
professionnelles
permettre à leurs communautés de se
rencontrer en offline ce qu'on se rend
compte que c'est des réseaux qui sont
très vastes on a parfois connecte à des
centaines voire des milliers de
personnes et c'est des connexions qu'on
n'exploite pas donc le but c'est
justement de permettre d'activer sur
réseau une dizaine de villes en france
adhère déjà au mouvement paris nice lyon
et maintenant versailles le premier
linkedin locales dont la villa est
organisée mardi 27 mars à l'hôtel le
louis plus de 50 personnes habitant ou
exerçant dans la cité royale et ses
alentours ont participé à la soie je me
bats souvent contre versa et celle belle
endormie
on en est une ville dynamique avec une
population souvent active des profils
professionnels totalement différent et
je pensais que linky pour est un liant
entre les différentes personnes et
c'était vraiment l'occasion d'être
ensemble au delà du simple profil
linkedin chefs d'entreprise drh
communicants ou encore auto
entrepreneurs les profils présents à ce
premier linkedin local versaillais était
varié toujours intéressant de pouvoir
rencontrer d'autres entrepreneurs et
donc d'élargir notre notre réseau
étonnant les profils
roulette même différent mais qui peuvent
apporter après
pourquoi pas
du business et des nouvelles de partis
militent et on se retrouve beaucoup de
versaillais et c'est très agréable
on se connaît parfois de vue et c'est
agréable pour échanger un petit peu un
nouveau linkedin local est d'ores et
déjà programmée à versailles le mardi 26
juin juste après le match de coupe du
monde de football france danemark auront
à présent notre dossier consacré à la
présence de saint quentin en yvelines à
l'international deuxième pôle économique
de l'ouest parisien de nombreuses
entreprises implantées sur notre
territoire ont également une activité
accrue aux quatre coins du globe
reportage
chaque début d'année le plus important
salon consacré à l'innovation
technologique se tient à las vegas le
consumer electronic show rassemble près
de 4000 exposants plus de 150 pays sont
représentés
un rendez vous auquel a participé cette
année la start-up saint-quentinoise et
viraux leafs on souhaite exporter sa
solution de mobilité novatrice nous un
an cherche plutôt des premiers clients
du distributeur pression va attaquer
exemple le marché américain
et puis un combat les investisseurs
intéressés au projet qui voudraient
rentrer c'est un peu c'est un peu large
nous on est dans une phase où on peut se
permettre de chercher un peu de tout si
certaines entreprises en sont à leurs
débuts pour se faire une place à
l'international
d'autres ils sont déjà implantés depuis
plusieurs années c'est le cas de presque
sommes implantés à montigny le
bretonneux
ces pme qui existe depuis plus de 35 ans
est spécialisé dans les équipements et
systèmes de gestion de communication
pour les réseaux critiques
ce sont les réseaux qui équipe
la gendarmerie la police les pompiers le
samu les autoroutes certains aéroports
enfin bref toutes les toutes les entités
qui ont une mission critique a assuré
qu'ils ont besoin pour cela de moyens de
communications sécurisées avec une
disponibilité
l'entreprise compte 65 salariés répartis
sur le site principal de montigny le
bretonneux mais aussi sur le site de
recherche et développement à lannion
presse comme affiché en 2010 est un
chiffre d'affaires de 9 millions d'euros
20 % de ce chiffre a été réalisée à
l'étranger
on est présent en suisse et en belgique
depuis depuis très longtemps au mexique
également au canada on est présent
également en côte d'ivoire on est et on
est aussi dans certains pays au
moyen-orient tels que les émirats arabes
unis voilà donc ces cétacés assez variés
on est une petite société donc ça dépend
l'opportune des opportunités qui se
présentent
sachant que pour la plupart d'eux
la plupart des opérations qu'on réalise
à l'étranger on les réalise non pas seul
mais avec des intégrateurs des
partenaires à guyancourt l'entreprise de
jeux de société à ce mode et emploie
plus de 600 personnes à travers le monde
avec 450 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires la société présente dans une
dizaine de pays européens et poursuit
son développement à l'international
j'ai démarré le marché n'a qu en 2006
j'étais parti là bas donc aujourd'hui on
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire là
bas mais on n'a jamais une forte poster
de dévolution de croissance aux états
unis
on a développé un bureau en chine qui
est un marché émergent sur le jeu pour
compliquer culturellement et ces femmes
des structures de distribution bien
différentes mais on apprend
tranquillement mais sûrement
enfin parmi les grands groupes ayant
leur siège social à saint quentin en
yvelines et qui rayonne à
l'international
on retrouve jc decaux présent dans plus
de 80 pays ou encore zodiac aerospace
qui emploie trente cinq mille personnes
sur la planète et m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau lander ayadi bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le fondateur de numerix vous
êtes basé à montigny le bretonneux
alors parlez nous de votre entreprise l
existe depuis quand elle existe depuis
2012 2012 donc effectivement donc on a
commencé dans un petit bureau de 24 m²
au centre caméra au central gare donc
non loin d'ici bon effectivement donc
c'est une aventure et on est fiers donc
du 24 m² donc on a évolué effectivement
par la suite on a pris donc des locaux
un peu plus important donc de 70 m² et
puis dernièrement on n'est pas loin de
votre local ou 2 boulevard vauban est là
aujourd'hui donc on est sur un beau
bâtiment le fluo restons avec à peu près
de 150 m² donc aujourd'hui donc
numérique ce ces sociétés qui est actif
ces startups donc qui actifs dont les
nouvelles technologies donc
essentiellement donc l'architecturé
développement logiciel c'est aussi donc
des problématiques dont de big data
mining mais aussi mais aussi la
cybersécurité donc là
aujourd'hui c'est une entreprise qui
fait la croissance donc elle a fait la
croissance depuis son démarrage depuis
2012 jusqu'à maintenant il a aujourd'hui
on est une soixantaine de personnes et
démarrer alors effectivement donc moi
quand j'ai démarré donc au départ donc
je me suis associé donc avec un groupe
germano tunisien au départ pour
effectivement donc avoir un peu du
capital de départ mais aussi surtout
donc de tels appuis logistiques ont été
amenés en termes d'activité est
effectivement j'avais besoin aussi donc
du nez soit la grotte est donc
effectivement maintenant c'est fait
aujourd'hui donc c'était sur la conte et
danse était basé sur un collaborateur
initiale en allemagne avec siemens
maintenant je crois que de toute façon
il est temps qu'on puisse voler avec nos
propres ailes et c'est ce qui sait ce
que c'est fait donc depuis janvier de
cette année donc il ya eu dans quatre
changements capitalistique dans notre
société les assister exactement donc on
s'appelait donc c'est une absolue
technologie aidant suite à ce changement
capitalistique donc aujourd'hui donc on
est parfaitement en tenant parfaitement
indépendant donc en tout cas ce ça donc
je salue énormément donc l'effort de
notre partenaire bancaire je savais
aussi donc énormément donc le l'effort
de la banque
la bpi qui effectivement nous ont aidés
dans cette transformation est là donc
aujourd'hui à l'instant t donc on aspire
donc un avenir en tout cas beaucoup plus
royaux non on a déjà fait quand même une
bonne partie du chemin est là l'avenir
elle est quand même encore plus
important est encore plus rien alors on
va en parler seulement dans quelques
instants de votre avenir concrètement
quels services vous vous proposez donc
aujourd'hui est ce que disait c'est
effectivement c'est essentiellement
quatre heures ligne service donc le
premier dans le pré la première donc
aujourd'hui qui fait effectivement nos
activités d'aujourd'hui le jour c'est
essentiellement donc le développement
software que ce soit sur la partie haïti
ou à la partie embarquez donc
aujourd'hui donc actuellement donc on
travaille beaucoup d'un secteur
automobile donc pour ne pas le nommer
donc
le groupe renault nous avons
effectivement nouer des partenariats
stratégiques notamment avec le groupe
atos et donc ça c'est une des lignes
d'activité et pour lequel on travaille
aussi pour le secteur public donc certes
bibliques notamment avec le ministère de
l'intérieur
on travaille pour eux sur une plateforme
qui gère la flotte automobile de la
gendarmerie nationale
et effectivement on est vraiment fier de
ce projet et on espère le finir donc
d'ici au milieu de cette année
on travaille aussi pour le compte de
l'agencé nationale des fréquences anfr
on la surprend donc la tm à la tierce
maintenance applicative sur un certain
nombre d'applications donc chez eux
donc ça c'est une des lignes de service
sur lequel on travaille une autre ligne
est effectivement qui est maintenant
qu'ils big data machine learning et puis
aussi donc notamment donc l'internet des
objets donc à l'instant t donc on a mis
en place un certain nombre de solutions
qu'on l'a effectivement qu'on va pouvoir
peut-être proposer sur le marché
notamment le smart parking notamment la
smart agriculture donc là effectivement
et puis aussi on a aussi dense déjà
développé une plateforme ayew j alors
concernant votre développement à
l'international vous êtes présents
actuellement dans combien de pays
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui bon
effectivement donc si je reviens donc un
tout petit peu en arrière donc
effectivement on était un groupe
effectivement 250 personnes qui évoluent
dans trois pays donc l'allemagne et la
france et la tunisie
maintenant effectivement donc avec cette
transformation donc effectivement donc
là on évolue à l'instant t
premièrement donc en france donc là
effectivement les entreprises franco
française qui aspirent à l'international
donc effectivement vient de l'annoncer
donc la semaine dernière donc la
création d'une filiale tunisienne est
cette filiale a donc droit à vocation
dans premièrement donc chassé
effectivement les talents on est quand
même dans un domaine de pénurie de
ressources et aussi donc à voir donc une
fenêtre un hub vers le marché africain
et moyen orient pour effectivement
vendre naulleau
notre enfant après noël juste trente
secondes les 30 dernières secondes vos
objectifs à l'objectif très important
donc aujourd'hui on laisse une centaine
de personnes l'objectif c'est
effectivement donc finir l'année à peu
près donc à 80 donc effectivement on est
toujours dans une trajectoire ascendante
l'année prochaine effectivement donc on
aspire être effectivement à peu près 120
et puis l'année 2020 au nez on doit être
à 150 ça c'est l'objectif que nous avons
déjà tracée avec effectivement une
vision une vision qui est effectivement
base est premièrement sur l'humain parce
qu'aujourd'hui donc ça c'est
effectivement ça sur notre notre
carburant on va dire c'est l'humain dans
un premier temps dans un premier lieu
c'est la richesse aussi multiples dirais
que nous avons
et puis par la suite effectivement si la
qualité de nos offres c'est la qualité
de nos projets de r&d aussi on fait de
la r&d donc avec l'inria donc notamment
sur base de brevets que nous avons déjà
dans le domaine de la cybersécurité et
effectivement c'est la troisième fois
que nos avants merci mon deuil a dit en
tout cas nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage et tout de suite nous passons
à l'écho en bref depuis le début du mois
les grèves à la sncf ne font pas que des
malheureux
les espaces de coworking font le plein
de salariés qui ne peuvent se rendre sur
leurs lieux de travail en ile-de-france
477 espaces de travail partagés ont été
recensés par l'institut d'aménagement et
d'urbanisme
une carte interactive permet de situer
précisément ces tiers lieux où l'on peut
travailler à distance tout en étant près
de chez soi dans les yvelines
on dénombre une dizaine d' espaces de
coworking en mars dernier nous vous
présentions dans 7 8 et qu une jeune
start-up versaillaise vue bien vu leur
concept des lunettes design prémontées
de qualité et à prix abordable à partir
de 39 euros afin de lancer très
prochainement son activité la société a
choisi le financement participatif via
la plateforme ulule les précommandes
sont ouvertes jusqu'au 5 mai
on termine avec un chiffre plus 83%
cela correspond à l'augmentation des
ventes à l'international de l'entreprise
versaillaise cocktail games entre juin
2007 et juin 2010 est la petite
entreprise qui édite plus de 80 jeux de
société a d'ailleurs récemment été élu
exportateurs franciliens de l'année 2010
est chaque année entre 300 milles et 400
millions au total games sont vendus dans
27 pays
c'est la fin de ce set 8 écho à très
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]